how are you calling enough about me I'm
online how's the family my family is
great are the kids kids are great you
know I'm told they're fine anyway I
don't get involved you know what I have
agents and managers for the point is I'm
told you're doing well they're growing a
thriving how about you you got I bet I
would be a good dad if I was home more
with my kid you know but I'm just this
show is my priority you know I want to
rip me
my show is yours yes it is this my show
is keeping you from your child yes it is
Wow
I know you find that amusing but well
whatever you know I I came into my son's
bedroom the other night and he looked he
looked really sad I said what's the
matter buddy cuz I don't know his name
I'm never home he said can I be honest
with you I said yeah I wish you would
stop lying if that's what he said well I
was just thinking I'm 10 now and you're
63 when I'm 20 you're gonna be 73 when
I'm thirty gonna be 83 he said you're
not gonna be around for a lot of my life
aren't you I said buddy body body I said
I'm gonna be around for a long time it's
your mother you have to worry about
she's not gonna want to hang around with
an old fart like me eventually
you know what yeah because no dad I'm
currently doesn't know my name either
yeah he said I'm serious there's kids in
my class in fifth grade I said you were
in fifth grade cuz yeah the parent their
parents are like in their 30s their
early 30s I said that doesn't mean
anything there's no guarantee doesn't
mean a thing well you know who says
they're not gonna die in a fiery car
crash tomorrow you know or a
murder-suicide you don't know
and who says you're gonna outlive me you
don't know that I mean who's to say a
murdering clowns not going to come in
your bedroom tonight that has happened
before
anyway I kissed him on the forehead I
said you get a good night's sleep we'll
talk about you know we didn't we haven't
talked about your your lovely wife Susan
I love your wife she's a she's a very
funny woman's Brera you don't how did
you guys meet
um you want me to be honest yeah all
right
I met her uh I met her at a costume
party actually you met a costume party
about 15 years ago that's so crazy
yeah she came as a slinky that was her
costumes yeah I never saw them before I
thought this girl is creative yeah she's
what but anyway I remember the first
time I saw her she was coming down the
stairs
[Laughter]
[Applause]
serious she was great she was taking two
at a time she almost made it all the way
down this there she got stuck on the
last yeah and help her down I ask you
anything
you